why do you start with character I think
that character is really what engages
anyone with a story I think that when we
watch a movie or a TV show or a short we
want to see a character we want to
connect with them root for someone
engage with them uh watch them Arc and
grow and that's where a story should be
built from from that character yes you
can sometimes start with a premise you
know but until you find that character
that is going to be the best one to tell
that story with
you don't really have your idea ready so
for me it's all about building that
person and they should be the ones
making things happen and it shouldn't be
that things happen to them so for me
character is the build the first
building block of any story and they
should be the ones that you're telling
everything from
what advantages do writers have for
those who start with characters versus
Those Who start with plot
I think that it depends sometimes on the
genre sometimes when you're thinking of
like an action movie you know you tend
to go more with plot than with the
character first but again in my opinion
it's always best to start with the
character because then you're mapping
the emotions of the story and that's
what's what really connects the audience
with your story they're not just
watching you know the fallback from an
earthquake they're watching the
character go through the fallback of an
earthquake you're watching someone go
through those emotions and you're either
rooting for them or you know wanting
them to die by the end of their evil you
know but that's really what is going to
make or break your story is the way we
connect with them that's why it's so
important the way you introduce the
character uh hopefully in action and we
immediately connect with them and then
we watch their Journey we want to watch
them grow or change or be affected by
the events of the story so if it's
things happening to them and they're
just reacting it's not as active it's
kind of passive and more boring for the
audience what we want is characters who
make decisions they might be the wrong
ones you know and that can sometimes be
better because it's more exciting to
watch them you know suffer and have
obstacles you know or be their own
obstacles but it's much more interesting
when they're making decisions to do
something or not do something
so even if let's say a writer is going
to do a story about a specific time okay
let's just say the Great Recession 2008.
if we look at some of the stories The
Big Short uh Margin Call they had
characters that drove the story it
wasn't just you you know see like a
headline of the Wall Street Journal or
something oh you know the Market's
tanking we're seeing the characters be
in in that world and and different
things are happening yeah that's the
thing for example a classic that I'm
assuming everyone's seen Titanic it's a
story we've seen before and we've read
about it and there have been stories
before we all know it but we still love
watching that because we're watching
Cade Winslet and Diego DiCaprio have
this amazing love story right and that's
what we connect with the story Remains
the Same the backdrop is the same we
still watch you know the Titanic and the
iceberg and all of that happens but what
we're connecting with is their love
story and their evolution and Kate
Winslet going from this princess the
almost type you know to falling for this
guy that she would have never met had
she not been there and then giving
everything up just because she was
changed by having loved this man even
though it was only a couple of days you
know she changed the course of her life
and then we see at the very end you know
those pictures she wrote uh you know
horses and did things that she never
thought she would do because she would
not have had that life had she not met
him so it's all about those characters
why do you write bios for all of your
characters I
have a bias for the characters really
help the writer get to know their
characters before they approach the page
a lot of those bios don't even make it
to the page so there's that thing where
a lot of writers are like why should I
spend so much time working in a
character bio if I'm not gonna see that
well it's because that's what makes you
think of characters as three-dimensional
people with layers to themselves if you
think about you know how they grew up
then maybe they speak speak in a certain
way you know or they have this kind of
like past where
you know their dad left them when they
were little and maybe the story has
nothing to do with that in the sense of
like it doesn't start with the dad
leaving them and all of that but there's
always that thing in the character you
know as they're going about things maybe
the reason they have relationship issues
is because of that backstory so thinking
of all of those pieces and writing the
bias for your characters is really a way
to flesh them out get to know them so
when you're writing on the page then
they have unique personalities they have
a unique voice because of what happened
in their past they speak in a certain
way maybe a person is really shy and
they don't say enough because of
something that you set up in that
backstory and that bio that you created
and that's what makes them a certain way
or maybe they had so many incidents in
their past that made them very jaded so
they're very jaded and witty in the way
they speak you know uh for example in
France you know you have Chandler Bing
who just us talks with kind of jokes all
the time because he's deflecting and he
has a backstory that we get to know
pieces of it throughout the show you
know and it's not just exposed right
away but he had a history with his
parents and that horrible divorce that
happened during Thanksgiving and all of
that and cheating and all of that
involved uh but all of that backstory
that they wrote for that character
created his voice that's the way he
talks and he talks like that because of
that little boy that was created in that
bio that had that backstory that he's
always deflecting and trying to be the
funny one so it's not to think about
maybe the reality of what was happening
to him so working on those bios helps
you flush them out and make those
characters become real and when you're
analyzing a script that's what you want
right you want characters that feel
realistic that speak in a way that is
natural and organic and that they don't
all sound the same that's a critical
thing I always see in scripts you know
and a typical note I give is like all of
your characters sound like the same
person if I was reading them without
reading the character name I wouldn't
know who's talking so when you're
thinking of your bio think of even those
things you know oh they're jaded so
maybe they're always talking like this
or saying things like that that it's
going to make them sound different the
way real people are right we don't all
talk the same I'm more like the chipper
personality and I talk a lot my husband
is really quiet you know like we're a
good match in that sense I'm like I make
him talk and then he's grumpier and I'm
like this chipper and we don't sound the
same but on the page a lot of people
just write all of them sounding like the
exact same person and no we're different
so those bios help you create that and
transfer that to the page
the character bio so much of it is
really for that writer to have in their
back pocket and just know who the the
person is and drive that story forward
with all of these things yes
um at what point do we say you know what
we're putting too much of the bio in the
story we don't need our audience to know
all of this I think it depends whether
you're writing a feature or you're
writing for television it's very
different the way you approach a
character bio so if you're talking about
a feature yes a lot of times you don't
need all of that it can be layered and
just be there for you as a writer and
you put little things here and there
that just make them feel
three-dimensional you know you don't
need to mention all of the things that
made them who they are just let some of
those things like kind of slide in if
you're writing for television on the
other hand the bio is essential because
in the pilot you're just teasing a few
things but everything that you've
created is what's going to come out for
Seasons to come so when you're writing
those bio goes that's where the show
bible really comes in because you're
writing this huge document where
hopefully if your show gets made you
know your writing staff is sort of in
your head by reading this Bible and
knows everything you've thought about
the show for Seasons to come because
you're writing the entire backstory all
of the siblings all of the drama with
their parents everything that happened
when they grew up all of those little
things that you're sort of setting up
and then throughout the seasons we'll
get to know so perhaps in season one
they mention
having a sibling you know but we don't
actually get to meet that sibling till
years down the line like it happened in
Big Bang Theory with Sheldon we meet the
sister like way down the line then
obviously we see the uh young Sheldon
you know where the sister is part of the
show but in the original we don't meet
her till later or in the case of friends
we always knew that Rachel had two
sisters we don't get to meet them till
way down the line but all of that was
created in the bias of the characters
and we heard about them in the first
couple of Seasons even if it took
Seasons to meet them but that made that
character someone you know we always
knew oh she has these two sisters you
know that created a dynamic in the
family of who they were and then we get
to meet them so it's different when
you're thinking television versus
features I guess
how does a character's flaw relate to
the character's goal I think that they
should be intimately connected in that
their flow should be a big obstacle to
their goal you know so if they want to
achieve something in the end whatever
flaw they have should impede that so for
example if a character
uh
needs by The End by the end of the story
you know to deliver this big speech like
The King's Speech you know literally
that movie you know his flow is the
stutter right and he needs to deliver a
speech literally so they need to be
connected right the goal is that and
then the flaw is impeding that and what
we're tracking throughout the story is
exactly the evolution he works with a
speech therapist right that tries to get
ahead tries to tackle the root of his
fear the root of his stutter and evolves
in a way that then leads to that final
goal so those two should be intimately
connected and that's really what creates
the Arc of your protagonist and what
you're tracking again as we were talking
before all of the turning points of the
story are about that right the inciting
incident could be like you need to
deliver this speech and then towards the
end it will be delivering it which will
be the climax but all of the turning
points she connect with